-My first guest tonight is
an Emmy-nominated actor.
Man, he hits it out of the park.
You can see him
on "This Is Us,"
which airs Tuesdays at 9:00 P.M.
on NBC.
Here is Milo Ventimiglia,
everybody.
Yo!
-What's up, Jimmy?
What's up, man?
-Milo, it is great
to see you, pal.
Thank you so much for coming
on the show.
-I know, through all
the ones and zeros, man.
That's how we do it these days.
-It's unbelievable, right?
Are you on set right now?
-Yeah.
No, I'm in my office
in Los Angeles.
-Okay.
-But the studio, Paramount,
where we film,
is like a block away.
-Do you film at Paramount?
I did not know that.
-Yeah, we're at Paramount.
We are, man.
-That's where Lorne hired me
for "Saturday Night Live."
-No, really?
-Out in the lot, in his -- yeah,
he had an office on the lot.
-By the way,
that was such an
incredible audition tape.
I watched it. It popped up,
you know, in my thought.
I watched not like
three weeks ago.
-No.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
It's so embarrassing.
-It was incredible.
-No.
-It's not -- it's not
embarrassing.
That's like -- that's like
early days.
That's salad days, man.
That's good stuff.
-I mean, that was like --
I wore the tightest clothes
I've ever seen in my --
I don't know.
I think I was like auditioning
for Cirque du Soleil
or something.
I was something --
I was like --
-Yeah, but it was also --
it was the '90s, right?
-Yeah. Yeah, like 2000.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, late '90s, '98.
-Late '90s, yeah.
So that was the transition
going out of the grunge into --
-Yes.
-Yeah. I remember.
-And you know, weirdly enough,
I based my haircut
on a photoshoot I saw
in a magazine
of Kate Beckinsale.
She had -- she cut her spikey
and short for some movie
and I thought she looked
so cool, and I was like,
"I'm gonna do that haircut."
It's so dumb,
but it's the truth.
-That's incredible.
-Isn't that weird?
-That's amazing.
-I had so many fads --
-Yeah.
-...of hairstyles and
ridiculousness.
But I love Paramount so much.
-Yeah.
-Milo, I got to talk to you
about this 'cause you did
something that --
I love that you do what you say.
You said, "Dude, I'm gonna get
an Airstream.
I'm gonna like travel,"
and I go, "Love it, man.
I can't wait."
But you did.
You bought an Airstream.
-Yeah.
-And you drove it around
the U.S.
I want to know every single
detail.
I want to know everything.
Look at this thing.
I love Airstreams.
-Yeah.
I mean, listen man, Airstreams
are sexy.
-Yeah.
-You know?
But I also realize it's kind of
luxury premier item.
So I call it my camper.
-Yeah, okay.
-I call it my camper.
-Yeah.
-'Cause it feels like it brings
me down to Earth a little bit.
-You -- it is.
-But, yeah, so --
Yeah, I think so.
I mean, you know, you're driving
around and you got this big
silver bullet behind you,
and it's sexy and it's cool
and, you know,
you can stop on a hillside
and you take a photo
and it's just incredible.
You know, vistas and everything.
But like the real truth is,
you're driving hours and hours
and hours and hours, and when
you're done driving 13 hours,
you got to hook up and line
and pump your own crap.
-[ Laughing ]
That's the part they don't
advertise.
-That's what's -- that's not
in the brochure.
-[ Laughs ]
But I mean, isn't it great
like when it rains
on an Airstream
and the tap of the rain
on the tin of the --
You can't --
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, it's -- listen, it is --
it is a travel like none other.
-I'd love to do it.
-And I'd always wanted to do it.
I know we talked about it.
-Me too.
-And so I did it.
Like, you know, quarantine
happened, and what was going on
in the world
was going on in the world, and I
wanted to go see my sisters.
One was in Utah and another one
is up in Oregon.
And as I was going through,
I was like
really researching this,
and I was trying to find a spot
where I could pick one up
along the way.
You know, I had my truck,
so I was good.
And then when I --
I brokered a deal
with a dealer up in Oregon.
So I bought it in Oregon,
and then I drove it
back down to L.A.
and then I drove across
to Georgia,
and then all the way back.
-Oh, my gosh.
That's the dream.
That's the dream, dude.
-Yeah.
-That's something
I think about doing,
and I don't know if I'll ever,
I mean, have the chance
to do it, really.
Just awesome.
-Well, you know what you
ought to do is, you fly out
somewhere where I'm gonna be.
We'll hang out, we'll drive
around the block,
and I'll drop you off
at the airport
so you get the experience of it,
but you don't have to worry
about pumping your own stuff.
-That's my man.
See, that's what friends
are for, bud.
-Yeah.
-I want to get to "This Is Us,"
and I want to talk to you
about the new season.
But during the pandemic,
people have been binge-watching
every show they can, and you've
been on TV for many years.
And my first debut with you was
"Gilmore Girls" and, you know.
-Mm-hmm.
-But can you tell
when people are binge-watching
one of your shows?
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, usually, you know,
social media will kind of
light up and you can tell
where the show was being
released and at what moment.
Like, toward the end of
quarantine it became evident
that we had a new season down
in Argentina, in Brazil.
So, you know, you see the
messages and people popping up.
-That's great.
-And then recently, I think now
they're cycling back through
it in Italy.
-Wow.
-And like seeing
what's going on.
Back in Europe, you're like,
oh, you guys are back indoors.
You're not out, you know, having
a pizza and coffee anymore.
-Yeah.
-I get it. I get it.
-Yeah, but I love that
you get to entertain.
It's global now.
You know, it used to be
just an American thing --
-Yeah.
-...American TV, and now
it's worldwide.
That's pretty cool.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, you know, and the
Pearsons are absolutely kind of,
you know, America's family
in a way.
But really what I see
most still -- still --
is people going back
and watching "Gilmore Girls."
It always goes back to Jess.
Always goes back to Jess.
-I'm Team Jess.
Day one, Team Jess.
-I know you are.
-Yeah, have to be.
-I know.
-Absolutely, buddy.
-Yeah.
-Oh, I love that.
I love that.
-Yeah.
-It's interesting that you play,
like, the bad boy and then you
play Jack who is the --
probably the best dude on Earth.
He's the nice --
-He's one of them, man.
-He's one of the good guys.
-Yeah, he's one of
the good guys.
But I mean, I'll tell you what,
those are hard shoes
to fill at times.
-[ Laughs ] Exactly.
-You know?
I've had moments in life where
people expect me to be Jack.
And like, you know, I'll be
honest, I mean, I think Jack
borrows from Milo
and Milo borrows from Jack.
Or Milo gets the benefit of
wearing the Jack face
all the time.
But man, it's tough living up
to it sometimes.
It really is.
If you notice like sometimes
when I do a lot of press,
I'll talk about Jack's flaws
just to humanize myself
a little bit.
To kind of let myself off
the hook a little.
-Yeah. No, yeah, but if you
are any way in a bad mood,
you should be like --
[ Deep breathing ]
"You got to be Jack right now."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Hey, Dad, you mind --"
blah blah blah.
You can't have a freak out.
-Yeah, yeah.
-'Cause like,
"Jack doesn't do that."
-You're like, listen,
I just -- I just pumped
my own crap from an Airstream,
sure, but yeah, hi. Hi.
-Behind the scenes over at
"This Is Us," you guys have
a reason to celebrate because
your co-star, one of our favs,
Mandy Moore is pregnant.
-Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Yeah, she is.
-Were you all back at work
when you found out?
Where were you?
-No, no, we weren't.
So over the course of
quarantine, we had, as a cast,
as a group, FaceTimed
with one --
or had a big Zoom together
and we kept up,
made sure everyone was okay.
But then, as we were getting
ready to film, we had a Zoom
with Fogelman, where Fogelman
was actually kind of giving us
the lay of the land, what the
protocols were looking like,
and if anybody was going to be
uncomfortable with them,
like speak up
or hold your peace.
And then he hopped off and we
were all going around, like,
"Hey, Sterling, you good?
Hey, Chrissy, Justin,
like everyone feels good?
Yeah, I feel good about it.
Mandy?"
And Mandy wasn't talking.
She wasn't talking.
And then she just kind of goes,
"Well, guys, I am pregnant."
And I mean, then,
you know, we're --
-Crying.
-Exactly.
Exactly, man.
Crying, excited.
You know. And --
I mean, she's the loveliest,
she's great, she's amazing,
and, like, to know that
a human being like Mandy Moore
is going to be a mom
influencing a child
in this Earth
just gives me hope for Earth.
-[ Laughs and applauds ]
I want to talk about this part
of "This Is Us."
This season that was hinted
how Rebecca and Miguel
got together after Jack died.
-Yeah.
-Now we might find out a little
more to that relationship.
But as Jack, how do you feel
about that relationship?
-Jack's dead.
So it doesn't really matter
what Jack thinks.
I mean, let's be glaringly
honest.
-Yes.
-You know, I think -- listen,
Jack -- Jack loves his wife.
He loves his kids like no other.
-Yep.
-But at the same time,
you know, Jack wouldn't want
his wife or kids to be
unhappy without him.
And, you know, I mean, look,
death is a pretty great
equalizer.
When someone dies, like, yeah,
I guess that's kind of over.
So it's not like Miguel got in
the way of Jack and Rebecca.
It was just, hey,
Rebecca was available.
-Yeah.
-And they had a history
of being close and friends,
and everything should start
with the friendship.
-Yeah, I agree with that,
by the way.
-Yeah.
-My wife and I started,
best friends.
We were just friends.
Loved hanging out.
It was awesome.
I agree with that.
-And then before we did
the interview,
you gave me your
wife's phone number.
So, oh boy.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, I'm so
embarrassed about that.
We'll have to talk about that
next time you're on.
But I --
-We have to, man.
That's incredible.
It's incredible.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't believe it.
-For anybody --
-Did she text you back?
-Yeah, long story short,
I was -- hold on, let me see.
I was trying to text Jimmy
something --
Hey, there it is.
She wrote, "This is incredible.
I will send to him
immediately."
-[ Laughs ]
I'm sorry, dude. I thought
I was giving you my number.
I don't know my number.
That's insane.
-That's great. That's great.
-That's totally real and insane.
Dude, you're the best.
-I love it.
-Milo -- I gave Milo Ventimiglia
my wife's phone number.
What am I thinking?
Milo, I love you, buddy.
Stay safe.
Thank you for coming on
and talking to me.
-Yeah.